Schönen guten Abend, mein Name ist Ujag, ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzarzt tätig und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Anamnesigespräch durchführen.
Damit sind Sie einverstanden?
Ja, ich bin einverstanden, Doktor.
Danke, bitte fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich bin Philipps Heinrich.
Philipps Heinrich, könnte Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen langsam buchstabieren?
Paula, Heinrich, Ludwig, Paula, Samuel.
Ja.
Und Heinrich, Emil, Ida, Norbert, Richard, Ida, Cesar, Heinrich.
Ok. Am Anfang auch ein H, ja?
Ja, ja.
Herr Heinrich, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 66.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin 4.5.1966. Entschuldigung, 58.
Ok. Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,78 Meter.
Und wie schwer sind Sie zuzeit?
Ich bin 80 Kilo.
Ok. Wer ist Ihr Hausarzt oder Hausärztin?
Mein Hausarzt ist Herr Schmidt.
Ok. Danke für die Informationen. Herr Heinrich, was kann ich für Sie tun? Was für Beschwerden haben Sie zuzeit?
Ja, Doktor, ich bin heute hier, weil ich vorgestern auf der Treppe geschützt bin, ja.
Vorgestern?
Ja.
Hat man Sie geschützt?
Auf der Treppe geschützt bin, ja. Vorgestern.
Ok. Es tut mir leid, das zu hören, Herr Heinrich. Also, können Sie sich bitte diesen Unfall genau beschreiben?
Also, wie ist das passiert?
Ja, Doktor, es war so gegen halb zwei am Nachmittag.
Ich bin aufgewacht um fünf bis 30 Uhr.
Habe nur gefrühstückt und danach bis etwa 13 bis 30 Uhr im Garten gearbeitet.
Als ich dann in den Keller gehen wollte, wurde mir plötzlich etwas vor Augen und schwindelig.
Ich bin dann auf der Treppe, es waren acht Stufen, geschützt.
Und es war auf der rechten Seite.
Ich war nicht bewusstlos, aber ich hatte das Gefühl, dass ich gleich umkippe.
Ich bin auf der rechten Schulter gefallen und habe mir dabei mehrere Stellen verletzt.
Ich habe jetzt eine Beule am Kopf, eine Abschürfung an der Wange, starke Schmerzen in der rechten Schulter, am Ellenbogen, am Handgelenk und an der Hüfte, Doktor.
Jetzt kann ich das rechte Handgelenk nicht mehr beugen, Doktor.
Und ich bekomme in den ersten drei Fingern auch das rechte Knie und den rechten Fuß tun.
Am Sprunggelenk ist eine richtige Schwerlung entstanden.
Ich habe viele Probleme, Doktor.
Ich verstehe Sie sehr gut, Herr Heinrich.
Es tut mir leid, das zu hören.
Ich möchte es sagen.
Herr Heinrich, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie schwarz vor den Augen, vor dem Umfall, nicht wagen.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie keine Bewusstsein verlust.
Ja, Sie haben recht.
Das freut mich.
Bei mir nur schwarz vor den Augen.
Ich habe keine Bewusstsein Lust.
Herr Heinrich, haben Sie vor dem Unfall etwas gegessen?
Ich glaube, Sie haben nur gefrühstückt.
Ja, gefrühstückt.
Ich habe immer gleich Sachen gegessen, Doktor.
Butter und Tomaten und Brötchen.
Ich habe nicht ganz verstanden.
Was möchten Sie lernen?
Ja, ich meine, kann es passieren, dass Ihr Blutzucker ...
Ja, ich verstehe.
Ja, Sie haben recht.
Ich habe Blutzuckerkrankheit.
Du hast recht, Doktor.
Okay, und was nehmen Sie dagegen ein? Darf ich fragen?
Früher habe ich Metformin genommen, aber seit ein paar Monaten spritze ich Insulin.
Morgen nehme ich 14 Einheiten und mittags und abends messe ich meinen Blutzucker selbst und spritze nach 5 bis 10 Einheiten Acrapit.
Okay, haben Sie nach dem Frühstück Acrapit gespritzt?
Ja, richtig.
An diesem Tag habe ich aber nur morgens meinen Blutzucker gemessen.
Der war in Ordnung und dann nicht mehr gegessen, weil ich im Garten bestätigt war.
Okay, alles klar.
Herr Heinrich, haben Sie eine offene Wunde in irgendwelchen Körperregionen bemerkt?
Ja, ich verstehe, Doktor.
Ich habe auf meinem rechten Bein eine offene Wunde bemerkt.
Rechte Bein?
Ja, rechte Bein.
Welche Region eigentlich?
Oberschenkel, Doktor.
Okay, und Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie eine Abschüffung am Wande haben?
Ja, ja.
Okay.
Herr Heinrich, haben Sie Schmerzen in der Brust oder am Bauch?
Ich habe keine Brutschmerzen oder Bauchschmerzen. Nein, Doktor.
Okay. Haben Sie eine Lähmung in irgendwelchen Körperteilen bemerkt?
Ich meine, können Sie Ihr Bein oder Ihr Arm anheben?
Ja, ja, ja. Ich habe, ja Doktor.
Okay.
Kein Problem.
Ja, aber Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben ein Taupeitsgefühl. Richtig?
Ja, ja. Aber ich kann das rechte Handgelände nicht mehr beugen.
Ja, okay. Ich verstehe.
Und ich würde klippen in den ersten drei Fingern.
Nur in den drei Fingern?
Ja, ja. Nur in den drei Fingern.
Okay. Alles klar.
Herr Heinrich, sind Sie momentan schwindelig?
Momentan schwindelig? Nein. Ich hatte nur vorgestern schwindelig. Aber jetzt keine.
Okay. Alles klar. Alles klar. Haben Sie Fieber oder Stoffrost nach Schweiz?
Ich habe nicht Fieber. Ich habe nicht das Fieber gegessen. Aber ich fühle mich nicht fieberig.
Okay. Das freut mich. Darf ich fragen, wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Mein Appetit ist gut. Aber ich mag nicht mehr Essen gegessen. Ja, ich habe gesagt, ich mag es sehr.
Ja, okay. Und haben Sie in der letzten Zeit unwirkulig ab- oder zugenommen?
Nein. Ich habe immer gleich gewischt.
Okay. Super. Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang oder beim Wasserlassen?
Ich meine, haben Sie Blut im Urin oder im Stuhl bemerkt? Nach diesem Unfall besonders?
Ja, normalerweise muss ich oft nachts auf die Toilette gehen. Ich habe Blut-Zucker-Krankheit.
Aber vor zwei Jahren habe ich kein Blut bemerkt oder andere Fäden in meinem Stuhlgang oder im Wasser lassen. Nein.
Okay. Das freut mich. Schlafen Sie gut? Haben Sie Probleme einzuschlafen oder durchzuschlafen?
Ja, Doktor. Natürlich. Ich habe Schlafstörungen. Meine Körperteile verletzen und ich habe Schmerzen.
Ich habe Schlafstörungen seit zwei Tagen.
Okay. Herr Heinrich, haben Sie gegen diese Schmerzen, also gegen diesen Unfall ein Medikament eingenommen?
Ja, ich habe viele Mal Paracetamol, 5-7 Milligramm, 3 oder 5 Mal aufgenommen. Aber es war ein bisschen geholfen.
Alles klar. Und haben Sie wegen dieser Beschwerden noch einen anderen Arzt besucht?
Ja, ich habe viele Mal gesucht, aber ich kann nicht einen Termin finden, Doktor.
Ach so, ich meine wegen dieses Unfalls, ja? Ja, ja, ja.
Kein Arztbesuch? Ja, ja, richtig.
Okay, alles klar. Leiden Sie Husten, Luftnot oder Leiden Sie unter?
Ich habe nicht mehr, nein.
Okay. Ist Ihnen übel oder mussten Sie erbrechen?
Ja, ich habe ein bisschen übel, aber ich habe keine Erbrotchen.
Okay, alles klar. Herr Heinrich, leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen außer Zuckerkrankheit?
Ja Doktor, ich habe auch Glutoktore.
Seit wann? Seit fünf Jahren.
Und seit wann leiden Sie an Zuckerkrankheit, darf ich fragen?
Es war sehr lange, ungefähr 15 oder 16 Jahre.
Okay, nehmen Sie gegen Glutoktore ein Medikament ein?
Ja, früher habe ich eine Metablock genommen, aber ich weiß den Namen nicht mehr.
Seit ein paar Wochen nehme ich jetzt, benaz April, 10 mg morgens, abends eine halbe Tablette.
Morgens eine Tablette, abends eine halbe Tablette.
Ja, eine halbe Tablette, richtig.
Okay, sonst irgendwelche anderen Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich hatte vor ein paar Jahren einen Hörstuch und habe seitdem den Dienistoktor.
Vor ein paar Wochen, okay. Nehmen Sie dagegen ein Medikament ein?
Ja, bei mir benutze ich Cortisonhaltige Orentrophen.
Okay.
Vor etwa neun Monaten hatte ich eine Strinöleentzündung, die mit Antibiotika behandelt wurde.
Aber den Namen weiß ich leider nicht mehr Doktor.
Alles klar, keine Sorgen, bitte. Also ich werde Ihren Hausarzt kontaktieren, ja?
Danke schön.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, früher hatte ich auch eine Scheinbeinfaktorrechte Seite.
Scheinbeinfaktor?
Ja, vor ungefähr, ich hatte einen Schuhunfall im Alpen. Und ja Doktor, um ungefähr vor 25 Jahren, ja. Und da wurde eine Platte eingesetzt Doktor.
Okay, alles klar. Herr Heimlich, sind Sie allergisch?
Allergisch? Ja, ich habe gegen Halsschnupenallergie.
Halsschnupenallergie?
Ja.
Was meine ich dann?
Halsschnupen.
Okay, also Sie haben Halsschnupen gegen? Also ich meine, haben Sie...
Ich weiß gar nicht Doktor, aber meine Nase laufen und meine Augen trennen, ja.
Alles klar, gegen eine Pollen zum Beispiel?
Ja, vielleicht, vielleicht.
Okay, alles klar. Herr Heimlich, rauchen Sie?
Ja Doktor, leider, ich rauche.
Seit wann und wie viel?
Seit 30 Jahren rauche ich halb Schachteln pro Tag Zigaretten, ja.
Okay, und trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke zwei oder drei Mal per Woche ein Glas Wein.
Okay, bitte nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht persönlich. Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Ich nehme keine Drogen Doktor.
Okay, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, habe zwei Kinder, ja.
Sind die Kinder gesund?
Ja, ja, ja. Hat Zeit, meine Kinder sind ja.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich arbeite bei der Post Doktor.
Bitte?
Bei der Post.
Sind Sie Briefträger oder?
Ja, ja, ja, richtig.
Okay, und leben Ihre Eltern noch, Herr Heimlich?
Meine Mutter hatte Krampfadern, mein Vater hatte eine Lungenerkrankung, er konnte schlecht atmen, ja.
Beide leben jetzt, ja Doktor.
Okay, haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich habe ein Einzelkind.
Okay, alles klar.
Okay, Herr Heimlich, das war meine Frage. Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja Doktor, was kann Sie mit meinen Beschwerden? Ich habe viele Verletzungen, viele Schmerzen, ja.
Ja, also Herr Heimlich, ich verstehe Sie sehr gut, aber Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung getroffen, hierher zu kommen.
Sie sind ja jetzt im Krankenhaus und bei uns in guten Händen, machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen.
Sie haben zu viele Verletzungen, deswegen werde ich Sie zuerst körperlich untersuchen
und dann werde ich Ihnen Blut abnehmen und ein paar Untersuchungen veranlassen.
Welche Untersuchungen, Doktor?
Also ich werde eine Computertomographie veranlassen, Herr Heimlich.
Was ist Computertomographie Doktor, ich verstehe nicht.
Ja, Computertomographie gehört zu den bildgebenden Verfahren, das ist eine Röntgenuntersuchung, können wir sagen.
Also diese Untersuchung...
Ist es gefährlich für meinen Körper oder?
Nein, nein, also diese Untersuchung ist völlig schmerzfrei und benötigt nur noch eine geringe Strahlenbelastung, Herr Heimlich.
Okay.
Also diese Untersuchung hilft uns, Ihre Verletzungen genau zu erkennen, das ist sehr wichtig.
Okay, danke schön.
Okay, bitte nehmen Sie Platz im Wartezimmer, ich bin gleich wieder da.
Okay, danke schön Doktor, ich warte auf Sie, danke schön.
Schönen guten Abend Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen und ich würde gerne über ihn berichten, habe Sie kurz Zeit für mich.
Ja, bitte.
Danke schön.
Philipps Heimlich ist 66 Jahre alt, 1,78 Meter groß und 80 Kilogramm schwer.
Herr Heimlich stellte sich bei uns wegen vorgestern bestehender Stürz auf den Treppen vor.
Dem Patienten zufolge sei er gestern Morgen gefrühstückt und habe bis 13 Uhr im Garten gearbeitet.
Danach würde er in die Keller gehen und er hatte ein Schwarz vor den Augen, deswegen habe er auf die Treppe, auf der rechten Seite gestürzt.
Nach dem Unfall hatte er kein Bewusstsein verloren.
Der Patient berichtete über eine Beule am Kopf, Abschüssen am Wande, Schmerzen in der rechten Schulter, Schmerzen im Ellenbogen, Handgelenk, Hüftgelenk, rechter Knie, rechter Fuß
und er habe eine Bewegungseinschränkung in der rechten Hand bemerkt.
Er berichtete über Parasthesis auf den ersten drei Fingern.
Außerdem klagte er über eine offene Wunde an den rechten Oberschenkeln.
Die Fragen nach Brustschmerzen, Bauchschmerzen, Parasie, Vertigo, im Moment aktuell Vertigo wurden verneint.
Der Patient habe viermal 500 mg Paracetamol gegen die Schmerzen eingenommen, aber das Medikament hat ihm nicht geholfen.
Er habe keinen Arzt wegen dieser Beschwerden besucht.
Bei der vegetativen Anamnese seien die folgenden bekannt.
Nektarie, Schmerzbedingte Insomnie und Nausea ohne Emesis.
Der Patient habe kein Blut im Urin oder im Stuhl bemerkt.
An Vorerkrankungen nannte der Patient seit 16 Jahren bestehenden Diabetes mellitus, seit fünf Jahren bestehende arterielle Hypertonie.
Vor drei Monaten diagnostizierte Sinusitis, die mit einem Antibiotika behandelt worden sei.
Vor ein paar Wochen diagnostizierte er Hörstut und Tinnitus.
Der Patient spritze Insulin, Acrapid gegen Diabetes mellitus.
Er spritze morgens 14 Einheiten Insulin und je nach den Ergebnissen, also Blutzuckerwerte, spritze er Mittag und Abends 5 bis 10 Einheiten Insulin.
Er habe früher Metformin eingenommen gegen Diabetes mellitus.
Der Patient nehme momentan, im April, 10 mg morgens ein Tabletten und abends eine halbe Tablette ein.
Früher habe er ein Betablocker eingenommen, aber der Name von Medikament sollte geklärt werden.
Der Patient benutze einen Cortison oder Tropfen bei Bedarf gegen Tinnitus.
Vor 25 bis 20 Jahren hat er sich eine rechtseitige Tibiafraktur bei einem Skionfall zugezogen, die operativ behandelt worden sei.
Er habe Rollenallergien, die sich durch Rhinokonjunktivitis äußert.
Er ist Raucher, er raucht seit 30 Jahren 10 g täglich.
Das entschiebt 15 Pakete.
Er trinkt 2 bis 3 Mal ein Glas Wein pro Woche.
Drogenkosun wurde verneint.
In der Familienanamnese gab er an, dass die Mutter an Varicoze leide und der Vater leide an COPD.
Er sei Einzelkind, verheiratet und er habe 2 gesunde Kinder.
Er sei Briefträger von Beruf.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf eine Polytrauma aus, da der Patient typische Symptome dafür aufweist.
Der Patient hatte einen gestürzt auf die rechte Seite, auf einer Treppe, die 8 Stufen ist.
Deswegen leidet der Patient unter Kopfschmerzen, rechtseitige Körperteile Schmerzen, Arm, Bein, Handgelenk.
Diese Symptome sprechen für eine Polytrauma.
Als Differenz der Diagnosen kommen Gehirnerschütterung oder Gehirnblutung in Betracht.
Um meine Verdacht Diagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich den Patienten die Vitalparameter überwachen und eine neurologische und körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei der neurologischen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob Störungen der Motorik, Sensorik, Durchblutung und andere Funktionen vorliegen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob sichere oder unsichere Frakturzeichen vorhanden sind.
Zusätzlich ist eine Labouruntersuchung sinnvoll, um eine umfassende Diagnostik zu gewährleisten.
Dabei würde ich Blutbild, CAP, BSG, Leberwerte, Nierenwerte, Blutgruppen, Gehirnungsparameter bestimmen lassen.
Danach würde ich eine CT-Computer-Tomographie von Kopf bis Fuß durchführen, um die möglichen Verletzungen genau zu beurteilen.
Danach würde ich eine Abdomenssonographie durchführen, um die möglichen Pathologien, wie zum Beispiel Freiflüssigkeit oder Blutungen, genau zu überprüfen.
Sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Ich würde den Patienten einen Venösenzugang legen.
Ich würde den Patienten eine Flüssigkeit zuvor, Analgetika, Antiemetika verabreichen.
Danach würde ich ein orthopädisches Konzil anfordern, um die Therapie des Patienten zu optimieren.
Wenn Sie dieser Vergehensweise einverstanden sind, werde ich mit der geplanten Untersuchung fortfahren.
Herr Oberst, wann hat der ja Ihre Tetanusimpfungen aufgestellt?
Diese Frage habe ich leider nicht gestellt. Sie haben recht. Ich werde diese Frage nach dem Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch gerne stellen.
Hat er Ihre Wunden gewischt oder desinfiziert?
Auch diese Frage habe ich nicht gestellt, Herr Oberst.
Würden Sie während der Körperliche Untersuchung Glasgow Coma Scala überwachen und die populäre Reaktion des Lichts überprüfen?
Ja, ich würde den Patienten Glasgow Coma Scala überprüfen und die populäre Reaktion des Lichts überprüfen.
Das ist sehr wichtig.
Möchten Sie in diesem Fall röntgen?
Normalerweise.
Und welche?
Ja, ich würde ein CT von Kopf bis Fuß überprüfen lassen.
Deswegen brauche ich keine Rundkernuntersuchung, Herr Oberst.
Rechte Schulter, rechte Ollomboge, rechte Handgelenk.
Für die Frakturen genau zu der Unterteilung.
Rechte Beine.
Welche Frakturen können Sie während des CT diagnostizieren?
Fraktur des Schädels können wir feststellen oder Thorexbereich Fraktur oder Hüftgelenkfraktur können wir und Assetabellungfraktur können wir feststellen.
In diesem Fall würden Sie einen Blutkreustest bestimmen lassen?
Ja, Sie haben recht. Es gibt eine Möglichkeit zum Operieren. Deswegen sollen wir Blutkreustest und Blutgruppe genau feststellen.
Herr Kollegen, können Sie uns die Fast-Zonographie im Abdomen aufklären?
Ja, ich werde gerne Sie über Fast-Zonographie aufklären.
Fast-Zonographie ist eine Ultraschalluntersuchung-Methode.
Wir benutzen diese Methode besonders bei Traumfällen.
Diese Untersuchung hilft uns die Verletzungen und Freiflüssigkeit genau zu erkennen.
Wir untersuchen die vier verschiedenen Bauchhöhle.
Wie kann man das sagen?
Wir beurteilen bestimmte Regionen.
Z.B. Subkyspoid, rechter Ufer, linke Ufer, rechter Unter, linke Unter und Suprapubik.
Diese Körperteile haben ein Risiko für die Freiflüssigkeit.
Wir beurteilen die Freiflüssigkeit bei diesen Körperteilen.
In diesem Fall würden Sie eine EKG und eine Ächokardiografie beschreiben.
Wir werden eine schwarze Augen und vertige Probleme vornehmen.
Ein Herzproblem kann diese Beschwerden verursachen.
Wenn Sie an Intercerebral Hemorrhage denken, würden Sie eine Lumbarfunktion beurteilen?
Wenn wir eine Blutung im Gehirn beurteilen, würden Sie eine Lumbarfunktion beurteilen.
Ich glaube, das muss die manufacturers vornehmen.
Nein, wir denken auf intresse Hämorrhoids, aber wir haben während der CT-Deschadens keine Auffälligkeit gefunden, müssen wir eine Lumbar-Kunktion durchführen.
Aber wenn wir eine Befunde beim CT finden, machen wir keine Lumbar-Kunktion.
Ich habe eine Frage. Denken Sie bei diesem Fall unkontrollierte Blutzucker als Differentialdiagnose?
Ja, das stimmt. Der Patient hat nur gefrühstückt und er hat viele Zeit im Garten gearbeitet und er hat seine Blutzuckerwerte nicht gemessen.
Deswegen gibt es ein Risiko für eine niedrige Blutzuckerwerte. Sie haben recht.